what is up everybody it's Santa Mack and
welcome to another installment of the
week's best anime videos where you can
come to catch up and all the fun stuff
that you missed in the past week the
links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments just
yesterday on Saturday I uploaded my
second code geass season 3 video and in
this one I was sharing some of my
theories of what I think is going to
happen in season 3 this video and the
first Code Geass video in which I talked
about why I think we Lucia's still alive
received a huge amount of support from
you guys so I just wanted to thank you
for liking for commenting and for
sharing the videos I have to say that
the comments in these videos have been
awesome you guys have been sharing some
of your theories with me and actually
you made me think of stuff that I didn't
think of before so the comments from the
first video actually helped me make a
better second video so thank you so much
for that now speaking of comments and
discussion this week
Aki Dearest came back from her trip to
Japan and she's actually been recovering
from some jetlag and allergy related
issues and despite all of that Aki
actually took the time to make an
appearance in the comments section of
the last episode of the week's best
anime videos which is just awesome and
you know what I think it's pretty safe
to say that we're like best friends now
right right but seriously though when
you watch your favorite youtubers for a
long time and then you start making
videos of your own you never really
think that your favorite youtubers are
actually gonna see your videos
especially if you're a small channel the
fact that Aki takes the time to watch
these videos I mean that's just like I'm
not gonna get emotional or anything cuz
I'm really manly and everything and
[Music]
but Aki thanks again I wish you all the
best I wish you a really speedy recovery
and keep doing the awesome work that you
do back on Thursday we livestream the
fourth episode of rent cafe where we
were discussing the future of anime and
I just wanted to say something really
quickly the rent cafe chat last week was
amazing so many of you guys came out and
contributed to the discussion
it was an amazing discussion I had such
a good time talking to everybody thank
you to our special guest cyanide
blizzard McClelland and Brin from
Brent's fandoms and thank you so much to
all of you guys who came out thanks to
one master in la viga who stayed up late
in europe to watch rant cafe live thanks
to soul maka he's new to the channel but
he's been contributing to all the
discussions and I really enjoyed talking
to him
I also saw Roger Smith 2004 and pause
and selecting the Chad those guys
actually make really cool videos of
their own and I really enjoyed chatting
with them thanks guys
I just really love that we are forming a
community around Radtke fan around this
channel and that we're discussing these
things that we love so much together so
thank you again it's such a pleasure
don't forget the rain cafes every
Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
and this week we're gonna be talking
about all the different genres in anime
so everything from sci-fi fantasy and
that general stuff to cyberpunk
steampunk magical girl magical boy I
don't know we'll talk about it also be
sure to join us 5 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time
this week our guests are gonna be Matt
Cole not Brent from Brent's fandoms and
Briggs from all-day anime is making his
epic comeback so don't miss it this week
the anime man made a video about how
underpaid many animators are within the
anime industry once again joy brings up
some really good points in this video
including the fact that the anime
industry really is in danger today
because it is so hard to make it as an
animator they struggle so much then many
might decide to just give up and go do
something else work another job and what
does this mean for the anime industry it
means that people who are creative who
are young who have new perspectives are
going to be kept out of the industry and
the anime industry as a whole is going
to stagnate this is a big deal this is
something that we should all care about
and Joey actually invited his fans to go
and support an online funding project
for struggling animators the project was
actually fully funded only hours after
Joey made the video which is just
awesome
and last time I checked the project had
more than doubled Afonso day
we asked for so that's really good news
I really hope that all of us as fans
especially those of us outside Japan can
come together and organize and create
some kind of initiative that will be
more stable and that will continue to
fund and help struggling animators in
the future I think that would be really
important if you guys have any ideas of
how we could do this in the future
please leave them in the comments
because I would love to hear from you
back on Thursday give [ __ ] uploaded a
really interesting review of the new
anime film ki mean old na wa see it's
not whether you pronounce it correctly
or not it's whether you look like you
pronounce it correctly confidence but
yeah this review is really interesting
because cook actually got emotional in
this video he really enjoyed this film
and he really wanted to share the
emotions he felt while watching this
film and it was pretty cool I mean it
was pretty weird to see could cook make
a video where he's not making snarky
comments every 10 seconds but I thought
it was an interesting change of pace and
I appreciated it
glass reflection delivered on his review
week of Awesome this week he reviewed
Tokyo ghoul Durarara JoJo's amazing
adventure the seven deadly sins and then
he trolled everybody by reviewing Avatar
The Last Airbender which we all know is
not an anime but that's okay I actually
don't have a problem with our cut or
reviewing content other than anime
because he's such a great reviewers so
if you like his anime reviews why
wouldn't you like his reviews of other
content definitely check this guy out
his content is excellent our rant cafe
guests from last week's cyanide blizzard
uploaded a new first impressions video
on his channel and this time he and his
friends actually reviewed Keijo know
when I first heard of Kato
I actually thought it was some kind of
joke like girls fighting each other with
their butts I was never gonna give it a
chance but after watching this video I
actually think there might be more to it
than that this might actually be a
really unique and interesting sports
anime so I'm probably gonna give it a
shot now
cyanide blizzard and Friends good job
and my favorite amv for this week was an
AME force in battle Vulcan the spin-off
of mati by a youtuber called Daisuke amv
this is another high action high quality
a MV that uses some amazing visual
effects so definitely check it out and
that's it for this week guys if you
enjoyed these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]